lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
hablar de los niveles de significancia
los cuales son de nota 2 por la letra
griega alfa vamos a hablar de dos cosas
las diversas conclusiones a las que
puedes llegar basándote en los
diferentes niveles de significancia que
hayas establecido y también el por qué
es importante establecer los niveles de
significancia de antemano antes de que
realices un experimento y calculé los
valores p esto último por cuestiones
éticas para esto veamos el siguiente
ejemplo raúl escucho que al hacer girar
una moneda sobre una superficie en lugar
de tirar un volado la probabilidad de
que caiga cara es mayor que el 50% y
esto resultaría fascinante de ser verdad
él provocó esto haciendo girar 10
monedas diferentes 10 veces es decir un
total de 100
sus hipótesis eran las siguientes la
hipótesis nula es que al hacer girar la
moneda la proporción no cambia con
respecto a la que resultan de lanzar un
volado se mantienen 50 por ciento contra
su hipótesis alternativa la cual es que
al hacer girar la moneda la proporción
es mayor que el 50 por ciento donde p es
la proporción real de que caiga cara al
hacer girar una moneda de las 100
ocasiones en que hizo girar la moneda
ésta cayó cara 59 veces ok
raúl calculó que el estadístico y esta
de aquí es la proporción muestral es
igual a 59 de esas 100 veces 59 veces
cayeron karam lo cual es 0.59 y tienen
un valor p asociado de aproximadamente
0.0 36
así que con base en este escenario si
raúl hubiera establecido de antemano el
nivel de significancia en no sé 0.05 qué
conclusiones podría establecer y antes
de que pausa el vídeo piensa en cuáles
serían las conclusiones si hubiera
establecido de antemano un nivel de
significancia de no se imaginan te uno
muy pequeño 0.01 pausa el vídeo y trata
de responder esto para empezar
recordemos lo que es un valor p asociado
lo podemos interpretar como la
probabilidad de obtener esta proporción
muestral es decir este estadístico
muestral suponiendo que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera
y ese valor es lo suficientemente
pequeño si es menor que cierto umbral es
decir este valor de significancia
entonces rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
en este caso constatamos que el valor
pen asociado es menor
mucho menor que alfa es menor que 0.05
debido a esto vamos a rechazar la
hipótesis nula en lenguaje común
rechazar la hipótesis nula es rechazar
la aseveración de que la proporción real
de caras que se obtienen al hacer girar
una moneda es de 50% al rechazar la
hipótesis nula
podemos establecer que se sugiere la
hipótesis alternativa de que la
proporción de caras resultantes al hacer
girar una moneda es mayor que el 50%
ahora bien qué sucede en el caso de que
el nivel de significancia es menor en
este caso el valor p es decir la
probabilidad de obtener el estadístico
muestral suponiendo que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera es mayor o igual que
el umbral es decir que nuestro nivel de
significancia entonces en este caso
estableceremos que no se rechaza la
hipótesis nula por lo que no podemos
sugerir la hipótesis alternativa así que
debido a la diferencia en torno a lo que
vas a concluir cuando cambian el nivel
de significancia es sumamente importante
que fijes los niveles de significancia
de antemano imagina si eres un
investigador de cualquier área te
gustaría obtener un resultado
interesante quisieras descubrir algo o
compartirlo con tus colegas y decir
oigan mi hipótesis alternativa es
plausible podemos rechazar lo que se ha
estado suponiendo el status quo ya que
he encontrado algo innovador es muy
tentador para los investigadores
calcular los valores per y
posteriormente considerar que nadie se
va a enterar se ajuste en el nivel de
significancia para
la hipótesis nula y reportar un
resultado significativo sin embargo
hacer esto sería realmente deshonesto en
futuros vídeos consideraremos la
situación en la cual si estoy fijando mi
nivel de significancia de antemano y nos
vamos a preguntar cómo decido el umbral
cuando será un décimo cuando será cinco
centésimos cuando será un centésimo o
cuando será cualquier otro valor pero
eso será en los siguientes vídeos nos
vemos en el próximo